les opposants au président nicholas
maduro ont gagné leur pari de convoquer
une manifestation monstre pour demander
son départ et apporter leur soutien à
roanne guido qui vont organiser des
élections présidentielles les
manifestants ce montré particulièrement
optimiste parce que jamais l'opposition
n'a obtenu un appui aussi massif de la
communauté internationale remerciant au
passage le canada sa position favorable
pour la pose de
guido et ses partisans ont reçu un
cadeau avant de sortir dans les rues
la défection d'un général d'aviation
francisco esteban ian s mais ce qu'on
leur colle entre les airs et à il est
temps de regarder nicolas mahut
je ne reconnais pas la dictature de
nicolás maduro mais je reconnais le
député juan garrido comme président 90%
des forces armées sont contre le
dictateur non xta.l et or sera-t-il
contagieux il a été qualifié de traître
par les militants nicholas matelot wang
wei d'eau reconnaît que l'effort est
loin d'être terminée puisqu'il a
convoqué une autre manifestation pour le
12 février prochain
les promenades euro avait aussi de quoi
célébrer le 2 février marque les 20 ans
de la prise de pouvoir d'hugo chavez
anniversaire que ne pouvait manquer son
vieux complice de l'armée à ses débuts
le numéro deux du régime
diosdado cabello à l'ordre du jour
mobilisation générale contre une
éventuelle invasion américaine qui pour
lui plaît
ça
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
nicolás maduro s'en est pris au
président trompe sacré il veut demander
à l'assemblée constituante d'organiser
les élections anticipées pas une
présidentielle mais des législatives
pour remplacer l'assemblée nationale
élue jusqu'en 2020 est contrôlée par
l'opposition
une façon de lui enlever toute
légitimité en plus de tous les pouvoirs
qu'elle a déjà perdu
prochaine étape demain de grands pays
européens devraient donner leur appui à
juan garrido et l'a dit ce sera le
groupe de lima qui à ottawa annoncera de
nouvelles sanctions contre le régime de
nicolás maduro
jean-michel le prince ray du canada
caracas